uh good afternoon everyone
welcome to today's planning committee
meeting it's good to see some familiar
faces returning me to sit on this
committee and I'm sure they along with
myself and Tony as the new chair and
vice chair will offer a warm welcome to
our new members
before we start today's proceedings Tony
and I would like a note of thanks to our
to to our predecessors putting on the
record Diana Ruth and Alan Powell they
both did a good job in making sure that
the committee was run efficiently and
fairly for all members and we will
endeavor to continue in the same vein
now as you are aware there are four
applications on the agenda today
two of these were submitted by the
council item five and item six
little more I'm ready
both are now
for the change of use of of amenity land
or the use as parking
I know it is short notice but I have
decided not to take these today
this is because as the new
Administration we are going to review
the council's parking strategy it really
wouldn't be appropriate for the
committee to decide on these specific
proposals in advance of this and if you
will pardoned upon I think the best
thing to do is we will park it
consequently
uh we will only have two applications to
consider item four stone broom and item
seven Court Thorpe
we will then have the report on the
planning Appeals
I am happy with this and we'll take it
in that order
for those new to the committee you will
find that it operates in a very
structured way
so that we can get to the point where we
can take our decisions on an application
if anything is not clear as we go along
then please let us know
the first item on the agenda is
apologies for absence
and we received an in advance I asked
Chad we received apologies from
councilor Anne Morley
thank you
the second item is Declarations of
Interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interests and or other
interests not already on the register of
interest in any item on the agenda and
withdrawal from the meeting at the
appropriate time do any members have any
interest to declare
uh not received
[Music]
move on to item three on the agenda
this is the minutes of the meeting held
on the Tuesday the 25th of April of this
year
are we happy they are a correct award
is there a mover I'll move that chair
thank you Tony
secondary
okay Council again
all those in favor
thank you that motion is carried
that's colleagues that brings us to the
main business for the meeting our
replications
before we start I would like the clerk
to explain for the benefit of members
speakers and those watching on YouTube
and we will deal with them
well thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the business this afternoon
sure will introduce an application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
these have been published on the
council's website
and hard copies have been circulated to
you
after this the chair will ask any
speakers to address the meeting
they will each have three minutes to put
forward their views
there will be a reminder given by the
Clark when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the three minutes members
of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary to clarify any points they
have made
after the speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the meeting but they will not be allowed
to participate further from this point
the chair will open up the meeting for
questions to officers
a debate by the committee and finally
determination on the application by a
vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
Barney members this meeting is being
live streamed and a recording will be
placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy this recording
thank you chair
thank you on
right let's move to the first
application this is Ned stroke 22 stroke
zero zero eight eight six stroke ol
outline application for residential
development comprising of up to 30
dwellings and other Associated works at
land to the era 14a to 54 I Street
stonebroom
major development affecting public
rights of way
in line with our normal practices
I'm going to ask the Punisher planning
officer to tell us about any late
comments and to give a brief
presentation showing any photos and
plans of the site
I will allow the officer to complete the
presentation consequently members unless
you have any
a point of order that you feel cannot
wait until the end please reserve all
and any questions about the process
until the end
um Adrian if you would like to work yes
thank you thank you
just before I start you I'd just like to
refer members to the late comments
report that was issued yesterday and
particularly reference to the two
photographs at the bottom of page 36 of
the officer report which has the
correspondent rightly points out are the
wrong way round the photograph on the
left looks towards the east and the
photograph on the left on the right
sorry looks towards the West so the
photograph towards the the East Side the
left hand side one is I suppose where it
should be the one on the right so just
to be clear on that point share
and just in terms of introduction the
application submitted in outline with
only the issue of access to be
determined this afternoon all of the
matters are reserved for further
approval should consent be granted
therefore whilst an indicative layout
has been submitted it should carry no
weight in the decision-making process
although I will
local plan and expected to deliver
approximately 35 dwellings it previously
received planning consent in 2018
there's still currently a Greenfield
site
the committee asked particularly to note
the Primacy of your development plan and
at all planning applications should be
determined in accordance with it unless
material matters indicate otherwise
officers of the view chair that in this
case no such matters exist to outweigh
the development plan
agreement has been reached to meet fully
the package of social mitigation
requested and 20 20 affordable housing
is proposed a number of technical issues
have been raised in representation but
there is no objection for any from any
of the technical consulties and nothing
substantive they've been raised raised
to outweigh that event advice
to go through the slides that we have
sharing eight Memoir to yesterday's site
visits
the application sites as you can see the
center of the screen is a site to the
south of High Street is joining the
existing development of stone room as I
say it's a site allocated in your local
plan for housing that's identified in
the committee report itself this slide
being a closer in version of that and as
you heard yesterday at the site was to
share the site to the set to the West
South West was already developed also
slide share shows the outline site in
red and includes the access to High
Street
and this is the indicative layout that
I've referred to does show how a number
of units could be fitted onto the site
but as I say this should Accord no
weight in your consideration this
afternoon as all matters other than the
access are reserved for further approval
in respect of that a plan showing how
the site would be accessed to the
highway it's submitted in this forms
part of your consideration it shows a
junction to High Street two ways into
the site with a side Junction off and
onto pasture Lane it does identify a
foot way to the West hand side of the
access as referred to in the report
and just in terms of a couple of slides
through Snape Memoir yesterday as I said
yeah this shows the junction from High
Street under pasture Lane looking in the
critical the easterly direction
and this is showing the same point of
access but looking in the non-critical
Westerly Direction and then just for
clarity chairs as I've mentioned the
photographs in the report on page 36 are
the wrong way around but hopefully this
matters clarified by those two slides
just looking back onto the site share
the site is in the center of the slide
it's the Greenfield area bounded to the
South by the hedge row and to the north
by the backs of the properties printing
onto High Street there is an existing
stable building just on the left there
the white building a footpath that we
saw yesterday runs along the western
side or the side
and that's at the hedge row just in
front of those houses to the middle
right to the photograph
thank you
colleagues we have seven speakers
cancel the cupid will speak to award
members
the book explains they will have three
minutes to get over their points they
will begin
Council Cupid
yes thank you chair it's sorry you
dropped out though is it uh is it for me
to start
yes everything's gonna start please very
good thank you chair
um thanks for allowing me to speak today
I know that to some extent the principle
of development on this site has already
been previously accepted by the council
because it is an allocated site and the
previous application was approved here
back in 2017 but this approval has
expired and I can't support the very
different proposals in the application
before you today
that previous application and the
council's annual monitoring of it raises
some big concerns for me aside from the
fact six years have passed and nothing
has thankfully happened with the site
which is indicative in itself various
ecology issues and problems with
progressing site have been highlighted
by the council's own monitoring with the
result that this site wasn't really
projected to come forward anytime soon
one of the biggest objections for me
though is the proposed access to the
site which Adrian's just highlighted
which this application is trying to
fully determine and agree on the pasture
lane and then onto the High Street in
Stonebridge pasture Lane is unadopted
and just shared access ownership with
the result that it's in very poor
condition largely due to the surrounding
rural land drainage factors and it
regularly floods it is however a very
popular right-of-way with residents and
walkers to therefore turn this popular
pedestrianized area into a major road
and Junction onto the High Street to me
would be really concerning the proposed
condition and proposal to consult on a
traffic regulation order to ban parking
on the High Street through section 106
funding in double yellows but I can't
see that will be successful as existing
residents as you could see from the
photos have nowhere else to park just
because of the the layout of the area
would understandably object and the tro
would therefore be unsuccessful so I
don't see how the committee can approve
something on that basis this would leave
up to 70 cars coming out onto the
currently very substandard Junction and
narrow roads
to further support this the council's
own policy assessment of this site
several years ago recognized the
Highway's difficulties and indeed
suggested finding an alternative access
may be more appropriate
as a final point that I want to make
whilst I know that this application is
only an outline and the indicative
layout is just indicative it is very
concerning to me it's very dense when
you look at it and it doesn't match with
the character of The Village the
surrounding Street Scene or the rural
area it was back onto whilst I know it's
sort of been said that it can be
addressed to preserve matters with that
I I don't think it can as the drainage
issues as I've mentioned on pasture Lane
and the proposed settlement Pond
that big area and so approving 30
dwellings in outline is basically
approving that indicative layout
with these facts in mind and the more
detail that I think some of the most
effective residents are going to
highlight today I hope you'll recognize
this application isn't appropriate and
refuse it thank you chair that's been
finished
uh thank you in terms of the queue but
um have any members got any questions
about the points which the speaker has
made in their presentation
nope right we'll move on to the next
speaker
uh which is also going to be on Zoom
that is Heather Powell
uh an objector
Heather can you just confirm
I'm not sure she's logged on there chair
um we'll move on to the next speaker
then
uh which is Margaret Kimber
I believe is in the chamber
um if you wouldn't mind um when you sit
down using the microphone yeah yeah
you just press the button on the
microphone
yes yes please thank you uh can you
confirm this is your name Heather yeah
no I'm Margaret Kim sorry yeah
Margaret Kimber yeah yeah thank you yeah
do you understand the process you've got
three minutes right thank you welcome to
speak based on the official manual
report from the coal Authority
2017 and 22. why is this development
even being considered when it has been
declared some area of high risk it
states that wherever coal resources or
coal mine peaches exist at shallow depth
or Surface there is potential for mine
gases to exist these risks should also
always be considered by the LPA the coal
Authority records indicate that a coal
outcrop runs through the northern part
of the site where the vehicle access is
proposed this coal outcrop may have been
subject to unrecorded workings at
shallow depth if workings are present
within the hour outcrop these May pose a
potential risk to service stability and
safety if there is any risk in the area
at all why is it being considered before
we bought our house 46 High Street we
had a national coal board survey done it
states that three seams have been worked
in the vicinity of our property between
1925 and 1948 ranging in depth from 200
meters to 260 meters we and the
adjoining property number 46 are cracked
under each of our Windows caused by
subsidence
I've lost
years ago 10 years ago we had both had
slip bricks put on the front of our
properties over the last two to three
years the cracks of Rio Kian
my concerns and if they're coming
through the slit picks my concerns with
they start digging and disturbing the
ground behind our property is it going
to cause substance again will we have a
guarantee it won't
previous applications
two previous applications on some of the
land were both rejected due to the drain
infrastructure also
the requirement is seven Trend water to
attend our properties over the years to
block drains into the main drain
eventually on a monthly basis in the
last two years which we concluded
compensation being paid three times
towards the spillage of sewage into my
garden no new drains have been laid
since this to take on the extra three to
four bedroom houses to be added putting
pressure on a maximum capacity
infrastructure also there is problems
with sewage and drains on the new
development of Carlisle Road one young
mum this week waiting two weeks 30
seconds left block toilet so obviously a
problem exists storm room school is the
maximum registration for reception some
people have not been able to register
for the new team doctors appointments
are running five weeks and then having
to travel to another Village and having
worked on the team with the neighborhood
for the neighborhood plan in the last 18
months Sharon and high in Parish I am
concerned about losing more green spaces
in our area also there's no Bungalows
planned on there which are needed and
lastly the parking on house
everything going through
sorry can you just wait to see if we've
got any questions from members that any
members got any questions
I am okay
um you mentioned obviously about the uh
you know the minds and the sorts again
that's all right that's not a problem
it's just a quick one really
um have you had a full Engineers report
or did you have you know yeah
it says somewhere
there yeah that was back actually in 19
when we bought them yes so we had the
full full Engineers report yeah it's
okay and now the collector was here
between this last two years okay thank
you thank you
is that it thank you very much thank you
yeah
uh the next speaker is uh Julia Smith
uh thank you Joe are you uh do you
understand the process yeah everything
okay if you'd like to speak thanks yeah
hi I'm Julia Smith from 32 High Street
and will be directly affected by this
development I'm very concerned about my
privacy being invaded about being
overlooked and knows unlike pollution I
have a large Conservatory which I use
every day and I'm much closer to the
boundary than the other type houses
which are closer to the road
there is double parking in places an
exit in madrab every day is a challenge
people already turn around on my
property as it's wide and open
as well as people parking for the school
people party with the forest school as I
have witnessed I feel it's a small plot
for 30 houses with potentially 60 plus
cars needing to exit I want maybe a
daily occurrence plus there will be
deliveries in these days of Internet
shopping
the photos on the planning officer
report of the exit from pasture Lane are
not a true fact as it's a reverse image
I emailed the correct photos on the
third which you've shown
the speed limit is realistic to despite
reports to the contrary there was an
accident in January near the school
speed bump where a car was speeding and
crashed into a Lamppost which had to be
taken down
High Street is a busy road with
articulated lorries garage and the
industrial estate Monday to Friday and
there's a thoroughfare for people coming
going to alfreton from villagers like
pilsley
a report by vectors in September states
there will be 7.5 percent more traffic
maybe for the first year but I've lived
here 27 years and traffic is increasing
all the time so what about in the future
so our strongly object to this
application and think using pastually to
exit onto the High Street is an accident
waiting to happen
that's all I've got written down but if
you live there and see that road it is
really really dangerous the state that
it's being used now
used a few Vehicles it's it's horrendous
it surrendous getting out of my drive
every day and getting in
uh thank you uh the members have any
questions
thank you
the next speaker on the agenda is uh
Stuart Ellis
thank you thank you sir you have uh
three minutes when you're ready so I'm
representing Chesterfield Royal hospital
so it wouldn't be appropriate for me to
have a view on the actual location
itself uh our objection would only come
if the section 106 proposals included in
the current report didn't translate if a
development went to head into a final
agreement and and just to help members
understand the impact of that so we've
been having conversations with planning
officers for over three years now
detailing the impact that has in
development within our area is having on
demand for the hospital
at the hospital is funded based on a
previous 12 months activity but often
takes a two-year cycle for this to to
catch up with the immediate impact being
increased where on replacement of
equipment and Facilities
uh Housing Development brings a greater
population for the area and a very
measurable impact for the hospital
health planning data plan for
significant increases in in emergency
attendances but the rate of development
which including Northeast auction our
immediate areas is 12 000 houses in the
last three years
um is already contributing to this being
exceeded with 9 000 more attendances
than either the stretch ambition from
local Authority and public health
planning previously
this has meant further adjustment to the
D capacity in the final years of the
build to to enlarge it further
with several million pounds worth of
cost pressure uh increase wear and
replacement rates on a wide range of
equipment means we're currently have an
unfunded replacement just as an example
of a million pounds for a gamma camera
um with other equipment like our CT
scanners having to be replaced earlier
in at a faster rate as a result of
increased attendances
the impact on the hospital of housing
developments become completely
unsustainable without the effective use
of section 106 which does account for
that but hasn't previously been drawn on
amongst other key infrastructure of
course
being able to identify attendance as
um to individual streets and homes we've
got some of the richest data to support
the requests which we believe is fairly
and reasonably related to the scaling
kind of developments we're clear it
meets the three tests of the regulation
and understand it's been accepted by the
developer in Principle as well as being
in use in other parts of the country
we'd therefore like to thank your
planning team for their support
um of helping us now move this forward
and felt matters are so critical though
that it's important to help ensure that
members also understood the impact for
residents and who at times obviously
become patients if the impact of
development's not properly considered 30
seconds remain taking place
so from our point of view provided the
impact on care the hospital has taken
into account under 106. and we're we're
neutral in that perspective about the
actual location which isn't a matter for
us
uh thank you does anybody have any
questions yes
icon
well I thought it was chair but it isn't
it Allen but it is now and you've asked
for 66
000 to for mitigated impacts to
development towards Chesterfield Royal
yeah can you give us any indication on
how that would be spent whether that's
or put the Royal whether that's out in
local sourced buildings doctors
surgeries so
um
Health funding is very complex and I
don't want to take up all of the
committee but there are two broadly
things so GP practices and the hospitals
are funded very very differently so
there's already a process where it
impacts on local practices for
contributions to be made where it has an
impact that they can use this this is
separate to that so this is for direct
use at the hospital to keep Pace with
the increased rate of equipment
replacement so we replace something like
79 million pounds worth of equipment
every single year and and that churn
rate based on increased attendances is
going up faster than the funding flows
back in which is where we've been guided
nationally that section 106 should be
taking account of that that impact
um on the uh on the initial increase in
volume
the only reason I ask is because Stone
Brewing being where it is they don't
necessarily get directed to to the Royal
to get directed off to
to Derby in King's Way and King's Mill
and all over the place yeah so if we go
the section 66
000 sexual section 106 to Chesterfield
how would that get uh disseminate
between those other hospitals so so to
to help with that and clearly you'll
understand for uh anonymity we don't
share the detail down to individual
streets but in work with the planning
officers we can identify What proportion
of every GP practices patients come to
us which go to Derby which go to King's
Mill so work across the Derbyshire area
with only identified and put
applications in around those where the
majority live to Chesterfield as opposed
to the hospitals and the arrangement the
other hospitals is the same as to
whether they pursue it or not but we
don't put applications in against those
areas where the majority of their flow
is to otherwise it just becomes
mind-blowingly complicated to try and
split bits of bits of money
um so we do it
yeah
so we do with postcode right so we can
be very clear the ones we're applying to
are mainly our flow
um patients
uh councilor Foster thank you chair
thank you for that my question is about
how this has been calculated when we
look at this it's 30 dwellings and
you're asking for 66 000 obviously
there's a lot of calls for the 106 money
uh and it's all as we can see there on
page 32 and 33 it's all coming from
different directions
and we know that it's up to our officers
and this Committee in which direction
this this money goes it seems to me from
the ones I've seen previously at this
committee that that's 66 000 now I know
when it gets to your hospital it won't
go far got that
uh but have you come to it's a lot of
money for these 30 houses
compared to what I've seen previously so
how is it being calculated that and I
know you won't be able to give me the
exact calculation yeah but it's it's a
nice round sum so how is it being done
based on these 30 dwellings or is it
like you might it might have inferred
earlier
based on money that hasn't been sent
previously to the hospital no problem
sure I can give you lots of reassurance
in here and
buy happy in a more detailed offline
briefing generally about about how that
works as a whole because this is going
to be an ongoing issue but the the short
version is is a very complicated model
that we've been through with planning
offices a number of times in a lot in a
lot of detail to help them see the flow
of how additional patients come into the
hospital unfunded there's a there's a
standard sort of cost for those of what
weedmic posters to to treat those and
the lag between the time when funding
then catches up at that point that
resource that we would be replacing
equipment with builds that hole and the
equipment goes on board so there's quite
a complex chain but it is down to actual
numbers of houses linked to
um the same model that's been used in
several areas of the the country as a
way of giving a objective way of what
does an average house in an area cost
and it's adjusted for the local area so
we're not using Wiltshire prices or
something for for here it's based on the
cost for for our patients so there
really is let's say we've got some of
the richest data in the country in the
NHS for kind of what you understand is
happening in your area and how it's
costed so it's not a we've we've plugged
a number it's directly related adjusted
for Northeast Derbyshire and related to
the number of houses and there's a
there's a value perhaps of what we know
the cost that comes in that will be
completely unfunded and take from other
patient care as a result of development
until that funding flows in a year to 18
months later
which is a is a chapter on its own which
we're very happy to to come into my
Martin and talk to her as a
there's a more General matter but I can
assure it's not just a number plus yeah
did a very detailed one also it's
sitting behind it
uh thank you Mr Ellis no more questions
and we'll move on to the next speaker
which is Angela Cooper
if you have three minutes now when
you're ready
proposal indicates that the developer
will adopt part of the lane
well who has the authority to give the
go-ahead for the cat because the council
don't hold the lane
if the council does give the go-ahead
for the adoption it should be for the
whole of the lane and not just part of
it if only part is adopted then the
water off this part will again run down
the lane causing more erosion
I and other landowners have been often
asked numerous times by uh passing
people horse riders uh who's going to
fill in the holes
and on numerous occasions people on the
lane have filled the holes only to be
accused by the owner of the land that
we're fly tipping and this is outrageous
there are no there is now two
underground Springs coming off the
proposed development side these have
have come to the surface and are running
all year round
what are they going to do with with that
are you going to reroute it or is it
just going to be left to come back down
the pasture Lane again
the fra make no makes no mention of the
ditches and the
and that
um sorry
that run along the proposed development
land
which at the moment
should be cleaned and maintained by the
current owner
this is in their deeds
this ditch has not has been neglected
causing water to run over and into the
lane
and half of it has been filled with
horse manure
photographs available
so if the development goes ahead who is
going to be responsible to keep the
ditches and the hedges all overgrown
again
section
18.7 of the fra says that excess water
will be allowed to flow not through the
natural Watercourse well at the moment
that appears to be down our lane erode
in the surface including our access and
everyone else is on the loan
this is not acceptable and a suitable
solution needs to be found
since the new estate adjacent to the
proposed Side
Access excess water that has been
allowed to flow through the natural
courses has increased tenfold
if consent is given our previous
planning conditions going to be applied
and if so a rethink on some of the
excess water and floodings
a concern
as I feel that you have overlooked this
on the previous development to the
detriment to everyone on pasture Lane
okay uh as sorry is that anybody got any
questions this week on points waste
cancel first force it
thank you for contributing that you
mentioned do you live down past your
lady that's where this channel would be
to there so your main concern is about
the maintenance of the ditches and The
Cutting of the hedges is that correct
obviously we're there the water is
coming off of that land because already
we've got it going down and I've got
videos and it's a fact So currently the
ditches on that land are maintained no
just you know some suitable standard
okay
if the development was to go ahead but
that was actioned and the flow of water
was managed more you know precisely yes
would that alleviate your concern with
this development yes I think it was okay
right and the hedgerows again
some hydros are kept in schemes they get
a payment from the government to to
manage them in a certain way
are they not cut at all currently or is
it no they haven't been cut for two
maybe three years okay
um
some some of the landowners do do uh
dig their ditches out but others don't
and the water coming off of that field
is a is a particular problem because
their ditches are full of horse manure
and haven't been dug out so aren't able
to go down the water course it comes
down the lane and takes the lane with it
okey-dokey right thank you very much for
that thank you
thank you for that uh we've got one last
speaker on this which is Daniella
Phillips uh the agent for greenfall
architects
you've got three minutes whenever you're
ready thank you
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is Daniela Phillips I'm from Green
for architects
um I'm here to say that greenford
development the applicant have carefully
considered the way that this site could
most effectively be developed in
accordance with the adopted policies and
the design philosophy set out in the
council's guidance in this respect
although the allocation was for up to 35
new homes we do not believe that the
site can easily accommodate this number
so our proposal is for a slightly more
modest number of 30 homes as the
officers report sets out we have worked
closely with them and the highways
officers especially to resolve the
technical issues related to the access
and ecology in particular I have I can
confirm that the applicant is content to
accept the planning conditions that are
proposed by the officers and the
entirety they will also need to be on a
need for a section 106 agreement to deal
with the various contributions that are
outlined in the report and the applicant
stands ready to finalize this in
consultation with the council the
contributions towards Education Health
and Recreation and open space have all
been agreed we suggested that the
contribution towards the traffic
regulation or therefore High streets
should be defined as a requirement and I
can confirm that the applicant is
content that the tro contribution to be
applied as the highway Authority's
discretion irrespective of whether there
is a problem or that will arise or not
although the detailed design and layout
of the site has not been completed yet
the indicative layout of this method
shows that the policy requirement for 20
affordable housing can be met
we are also very conscious of the counts
council's inspiration and respect of
sustainable energy usage on the site and
the applicant is already considering the
most effective way to achieve not only
these requirements but also to take
account of the poor coming future home
standards that will be applied in 2025.
the access scheme has been a subject for
a lot of discussions technical appraisal
and design work to ensure that the local
plan allocation can be delivered as far
as we can determine the local plan and
vision that access would be from pasture
Lane and so resolving the technical
details to achieve this has been a
primary area of activity as a result a
safe and practical design that deals
with pedestrian access the gradient and
provides management approach to deal
with visibility participants remain
agreed with the highway Authority
I would also like to point out that the
comprehensive and detailed ecological
conditions have been noted by the
applicant and there is agreement that
these are both appropriate and necessary
and although the site is relatively
benign and has been used as a pad up for
many years the potential for reptiles
and other other animals to be resident
on the side needs to be properly managed
and therefore the applicant is entirely
comfortable with these relatively
onerous conditions that's times yeah
thank you very much for your time
uh as uh anybody got any questions
thank you and then uh the resident with
the substitute issues just wondering if
you could
you could tell us or not whether pile
driving would be necessary on that side
with the with the underground mine
workings
without the site investigation I cannot
confirmed that uh yet but we have
submitted a call report and the call
Authority have come back with no
comments
and also
um have you got any any idea how you're
going to cope with the underground
Springs and the flooding on the lane
it will be resolved as part of the
conditions that will be carried forward
the at the detailed design stage
everything will be sorted
will the surface what sorry will the
surface water be
um going into the main sewers then
at the moment it's been proposed that
it's going to be a combined option but
um it depends that will have to be
resolved
and it is
manageable
uh count Julia
thank you chair
um I've just read through the report and
they are probably contributing 300 000
pound in section 106. with all the
comments and goings and deliveries from
concrete trucks and and all the things
that are going to go on and off site are
they doing anything with the lane after
they've finished or is that going to be
resurfaced as well
I presume they're gonna
um that part of the lane is going to be
adopted or subject for adoption Sorry
Miss Phillips could you speak directly
into the microphone thanks
part of the lane is going to be adopted
or offered for adoption therefore it's
gonna have to be maintained either by a
maintenance company or um if it is
adopted by the highway Authority yeah
it's that little bit of assume that
worries me I want to know that that is
going to be the case that it's going to
be resurfaced made good so on and so on
we are prepared to do whatever
for the road to be in condition and yes
we do understand that traffic from the
construction is going to cause problems
um and we are ready to
to assume that we are going to Reef uh
surface that option yeah thank you thank
you
thank you if you see it again please
thank you
hi colleagues you will now have the
opportunity to put questions to the
officers about the application
again I would like to keep this part of
the Pres the proceedings focused on
getting clarity about any points you are
not sure of
once we have done this we can then have
our discussion about the application
based on All We Have Heard and read
I would be grateful if you could not
move any motions at this stage let's
wait until we have all had the chance to
make our assessment
thank you
over to uh has anybody got any questions
absolutely thank you chair a question
for Adrian please or Adrian and the team
um I was speaking about section 106's
Adrian and we know we've had quite a few
problems getting section 106 money in
um I I just want to make sure that what
we're asking for is going to be
gotten shall we say I mean we're looking
at 54 and a half thousand towards the
primary school 224
000 towards Secondary School places
we're looking at the hospital 66
000 4 000 towards some ecology issues I
want to know that we're going to get
that money in that's the PO that's the
portion of it that bothers me
the applicant as you just heard has
agreed to pay the full section 106
contributions that have been requested
it would follow normal process therefore
we'd agree the 106 itself subject to
permission being granted and then we
would secure that money through the
normal processes expecting the developer
to provide that in accordance with the
covenants that they agreed to
yeah yeah I know we would follow that
Adrian and I I agree that's the way we
go down the route of you know we've had
plenty of these section 106's reneged
done in the past by companies going bust
Etc
that's what worries me is there any way
we can get that section 106 money before
before it even gets spayed into ground
is is that ever possible
that is possible if that's what you wish
to require however that would need to be
a reasonable ask and to require for
example the education monies before
development started in my view wouldn't
be reasonable because that expectation
wouldn't be delivered until at least
some of the housing was
actually occupied and lived in by new
residents so you could but my advice is
that that would be unreasonable and you
should follow your normal processes in
the vast majority of cases the money is
secured and in the majority of those
cases it is actually provided for by the
developer without us having to chase it
it's only the ones that become high
profile Where We Are seeking to secure
it through all the means that do causes
dicks but they do remain a small element
of the The Wider 106s I don't see any
reason in this instance why you should
be concerned about getting the money and
getting it an appropriate time during
the course of development information is
granted
councilor
Adrian this is a question for you
um I noticed here that the drainage
considerations raise no concerns amongst
the flood restatement local flood
Authority Yorkshire water and the
council's drainage engineer but
obviously we do have members of the
public here that are quite concerned
about drainage locally just trying to
ascertain because there is surrounding
land here that will have ditches around
it but I don't have any evidence where
they were concerned about
um maintenance of those
there is no
effect of flooding but the current
surface water drainage which has been
brought into consideration is there
anything in particular that we could
um
ascertain as to the Future and current
management of those ahead of the
development
the recommended condition 16 I believe
addresses that that issue that counts
the forces raised in terms of
a detailed design Associated management
to maintenance plan of surface water
drainage needs to be submitted to an
approved in writing by the local
planning Authority and members will
perhaps also note that condition 9 team
requires prior to the first occupation
of the development of verification
report is required
we um
we often hear of this and my advice is
always to members that the existing
situation of water management on site is
an existing situation you would expect
new housing to manage its own or to
Management in an access where else you
would have all the houses being flooded
so my advice would be that this
shouldn't be an issue going forwards and
subject to that condition in terms of
management I think that would provide
sufficient safeguard that this site
would be properly drained and subsequent
drainage managed you also um I don't
know cancer forces didn't raise this
chair but there's also the issue about
how the New Pasture Lane would be
managed and members again will perhaps
note that condition 27 seeks to address
that issue in terms of drainage of that
new portion of Highway off the High
Street so my my advice to members chair
is that these matters I believe are
properly addressed by the conditions and
that
never give a 100 cast iron guarantee
that everything will be all right but I
don't think is a there's a planning
Authority we could do any more than rely
on the requirement certifications as as
recommended by officers
Council buster
thank you chair uh thanks a lot Mr
Kirkham uh I'm looking through this and
somebody else might have seen this but I
can't see it I can see all the amounts
that have been requested by different
organizations
uh for the one or six women but I can't
see the total one or six money that's
been calculated so that's uh one
question uh second question is which is
I guess more difficult for officers and
I know part of the answer already but
I'll ask it anyway uh our office is
currently minded to a portion the 106
one is
thank you chair
I'll deal with the first the second
question first if I made sure because I
don't know the answer to the second
question I need a few minutes to go
through the mental arithmetic or the the
paper arithmetic probably if that's
important in terms of the 106 asks
members will note that in this instance
all the requests from the various bodies
are being met in full so as officers
we've not proportioned it up as we may
have done in the past where there's been
a suggestion that developers can't meet
the overall total in this instance
they're saying they will meet all the
total requests from all the bodies so
we're just
we've agreed with the develop actually
as you heard that there's been no
dispute about that the developer is
happy to pay all the 106 monies as
requested so we've just taken that on
its face and we'll
subject to machine granted we will
collect the monies that are requested
and and
Diffie them up if you like as requested
by the various requests or bodies so
we've not
as officers we've not sought to divide
them up
outside of that advice
yeah I wasn't aware of that from the
paperwork uh my question would have been
to the developer uh you know out of all
these do the does the developer agree to
be paying all of these I don't know if
anybody else thought that was clear but
was it clear to me that these were all
accepted by
I'm getting a nod from the from the
gallery there but it's yeah we had the
income confirmation already and right
it's just at section um 7.11 share is
where we've covered it in the officer
report and it says the above items have
been agreed with the developer and can
be covered with an incentively worded
section 106 agreement so we've just
taken that on its phase chair
no more questions for officers
right
uh thank you everyone for that uh this
led us on to the final part of the
process our discussion about what we
heard what we think
and what we want to decide but before
going any further I would just like to
ask the clerk to remind us about motions
yeah thank you chair
please bear in mind members that emotion
must be moved and seconded if before the
vote has taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded
then that Amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving emotion against
officer recommendations should comprise
the relevant planning issues and be
supported by evidence as necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls or in other words
it is not passed that doesn't mean that
the recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further Motion in
favor of the recommendations for a
different course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
thank you chair
thank you for that uh I would line that
now I'd like to open the floor for
debate
absolutely
thank you I'm just very concerned
because I do know that area reasonably
well it's extremely flat and extremely
wet and I'm just worried about this
surface water
um because there's a lot of it around
there and I'm just concerned that yet
again putting surface water into a
sewage system that's already overloaded
because I know we do I know that I'm
trying to say there isn't the problem
what there is in that area and it's that
that's worrying me more than anything
thank you
cancel the poster
I I understand your concerns I mean
water companies are under a lot of
pressure I mean we just have that
infrastructure put in for years
um the money isn't going into
infrastructure it's going to to
shareholders at the moment however
from what I've heard on what I've seen
in the uh in the plan it looks to those
concerns have been addressed it's not
sadly much we can do
about you know affecting the the
infrastructure of the of the drainage so
I think that's been addressed as early
officers recommendations
thank you Council
uh no more uh right tax Collies having
earnham read everything today and the
officer recommendations before us what
is the view of the committee on the
application
um I am now opening the floor to motions
I'll move the office's recommendations
chair
uh I think we're doing
a second that
oh second actually
so we've got no motions board so we're
going for official recommendations
uh chair would you like me to get
would you like me to carry out the roll
call uh yes please
councilor Cheatham
councilor Cooper
councilor Elliot
Council of forces
councilor Foster or
councilor Hartson
for
councilor Lacey
councilor ligate
and councilor Rouse
that's unanimous chair the motion has
passed
thank you
so uh if you can all leave the chamber
now and we'll move on to the next
application thank you
thank you
uh right
um as we're not taking
um
items five and six on the agenda I'm
going to move straight to uh item seven
on the agenda uh the application NAD
stroke two three stroke zero zero three
six five stroke FL
installation of a domestic vertical
windtime turbine at overhorn Farm main
road cutthorpe
resubmission of a previous refused
application amended plans
in line with our normal practices I'm
going to ask the planning officer to
tell us about any late comments and give
a brief presentation showing purpose and
plans of the site
I've allowed the officers to complete
their presentation consequently members
unless you have a point of order that
you feel cannot wait could you please
reserve these or any questions about the
process until the end
thank you over to you Andrew
I will take your members through this
one yeah thank you
yes thank you chair
um just to clarify I know like
representations have been received in
relation to this application as
mentioned the application 64 planning
permission for a seven kilowatt wind
turbine within the Farm Complex
slide please
the aerial photograph shows the
highlighted site in its surroundings the
site is situated to the north of the
defined settlement Court thought
within Countryside designated as North
Northeast Derbyshire Green Belt next
slide please
the site location plan details the
extent of the application site etched in
red including its vehicular access from
Main Road
this um
slide number four shows a more detail
plan I'll illustrating the location for
the proposed wind turbine to the
northeastern elevation of an
agricultural building within the Farm
Complex
next slide please Aid
um this slide shows the submit
elevational drawings which illustrate
how the proposed wind turbine would
relate to the aforementioned
agricultural building
similarly the computer generated image
submitted in conjunction with the
application
shows hosed arrangement with the
agricultural building
again another Community computer
generated impression provided by the
applicant shows an impression of the
proposed wind turbine this one being in
the wider context of the site
and the final slide
um it's an office photograph of Art
complex taken from an access track to
the north of the Farm Complex
um to summarize the office of
recommendation which is set out in the
committee report but note 54 referred to
in paragraph 158 of the mppf states that
accept your applications for the
repowering of existing wind turbines
post wind energy development involving
one almost more turbines should not be
considered acceptable unless it is in an
area identified as suitable for wind
energy development in the development
plan
in this case the Northeast Derbyshire
local plan
2014-2034 forms the development plan for
the area is set out in a local plan but
based based on the northeast Derbyshire
low carbon and renewable energy study
undertaken in 2011. the plan does not
identify any areas suitable for wind
energy development
as such proposals for wind energy
development will not be considered
sorry will be considered against the
government's latest policy guidance
on that basis officer sort of view that
the application is contrary to the
government's policy position on wind
energy development and consequently
cannot be supported therefore it is
recommended the application be refused
and that concludes the officer
presentation thank you
just before you you go on a chair you
will recall yesterday at site visits
Council Lacey raised two issues in
respect of the wind turbine its
proximity to the nearest residential
property and also the noise that the
turbine was to generate
and advise members chair that the
distance to the nearest residential
facade that's taken as lindahla I hope I
pronounced that correctly but the
distance is they're just in excess of 90
meters and the noise of the turbine
that's been submitted in the details is
that it is to be 35 decibels just to try
and give some clarity for that to share
60 decibels is a normal conversation and
80 is a ringing telephone so that's sat
in some context and just finally just
sorry to contradict Colleen chair but we
did receive one late representation that
was in the act that was sent out
yesterday
thank you for that
uh right colleagues we have two speakers
on the application the first
that we withhold in until later on in
the debate
uh we have two speakers on the
application the first room is John
Robinson Robinson the applique the
applicant
they will have three minutes to get over
their points they will also be informed
when 30 seconds remain
as members you can ask them to clarify
any matters that are being raised but
remember your questions should only
relate to the points which they have
already made
Mr Robinson you ready
thank you Mr chairman
this application is a small step in
meeting low-carbon energy goals which
you will all no doubt agree
one
the submitted Photoshop of the proposed
installation drawn with the turbine in
proportion shows it is very little more
obtrusive than a TV aerial and less than
that of a kidney stack
the first anomaly I can install that
wind turbine on or within the cartilage
of our house without the need for
planning permission
however I was informed that it is
necessary very to have planning approval
to erect the same small turbine no more
than 50 meters away from our building
under the same ownership and the same
address
the application meets proposals set out
into Brampton neighborhood plan which
are Farm lies this plan is with the
examiner present and there have been no
adverse comments on this item
counted Council have positively
commented on the high level of ambition
in it expressly referring to different
aspects of climate change DCC therefore
supports these aspects of the submission
draft
the officer's advice refusing the
application is based on minor 54 note 54
of the national planning policy
framework
I would agree with it
when it is used for three megawatt
offshore wind turbines but it's hardly a
pre a
applicable to a small seven kilowatt
domestic one
I believe the committee's decision
should be based on the more important
paragraph of one eight five six of the
same nppf which states
local planning authorities should
support community-led initiatives for
renewable and low carbon energy
including developments outside the areas
and local plans or other strategic
policies that are being brought forward
through neighborhood planning
six
significant number of residents of
capital including their neighbors have
sent in letters of support for the
proposal many with particular reference
to present low carbon energy policies 30
seconds there have been no objections
the committee's commission could
therefore be such that overrides these
unfortunate anomalies it also assists in
achieving low carbon energy goals and
goes towards meeting the councils
recently stated priority objective of
time tackling climate change thank you
thank you Mr Robinson uh has anybody got
any questions for Miss Robinson
uh oh thank you uh we have another
speaker on this uh David catton
you'd like to see please
thank you you got three minutes whenever
you ready thank you Mr chairman of
members of the planning committee
as you've just said Mr Robinson is a
member of the mission
to live off grid in his lifetime and
he's no spring chicken is he with that
in mind I'm here today to offer the
strongest possible support for his
application to install a modest wind
turbine to accompany his solar panel and
ground Source heat pump installations
both made some years ago he no longer
has a gas spoiler and he drives a
battery electric vehicle
for the past five years I've been the
chair of the Searing group developing
the Brampton neighborhood plan
which is now undergoing formal
examination Mr Robinson has been an
enthusiastic member of our group he's
contributed greatly to the plan
particularly with regard to our
Ambitions to reduce carbon emissions no
surprise there then
the planning department has made its
recommendations based on their reading
of the regulations the regulations has
applied to this specific application are
manifestly inappropriate therefore large
scale wind turbine wind farms
and have no relevance to this Modest
Proposal
the government announced last December
that it was Consulting on onshore wind
projects and subsequently proposed
technical amendments to the mppf
if the government is willing to look at
the regulations will the district
council support getting the regulations
changed bearing in mind that Council
leader Barker's statement made only two
weeks ago says battling climate change
is a priority for us as a council
a letter from any DDC to Lee Rowley
might have some different might have
some effect
perhaps in the meantime they'll use your
ability to make local exceptions and
approve this application
final information is still refused when
you get into your petrol or
diesel-powered cars after today's
meeting I hope you'll feel a smidgen of
guilt as you make another contribution
to global warming through the emissions
of the exhaust of your car
Mr Robinson won't
yes I also drive a better electric
vehicle and I've had solar panels
installed for almost 12 years
over to you guys
thank you Miss Camp has anybody got any
questions
oh thank you
colleagues you will now have the
opportunity to put questions to officers
about the application again I would like
to keep this part of the proceedings
focused on getting clarity about any
points you are not sure of so I would be
grateful if you would not move any
motions at this stage
talk to you
oh sorry
um just some clarity on page 84 we've
got uh paragraph 7.7
and we've got 7.11
uh I understand what the the planning
framework says uh I've read 156 is
quoted by uh the applicant and I've also
read note 54. I understand what's in the
local plan as well and uh to a lesser
extent uh the the new neighborhood plan
which is uh currently going uh
undergoing adoption
when we look at weight
we place on that neighborhood plan
my understanding was 7.11 so it's carry
right the neighborhood plan should
conform to the policies of the mppf and
if it doesn't then we apply no weight to
it
my understanding is and as this stands
the that neighborhood plan does not in
my mind I'm not putting emotion here
chair but in my mind it doesn't conform
to the to the nppf so we so we put no
weight on it that's my understanding and
we heard that earlier in the training as
well uh I think you mentioned it there
but we look at 7.7 so just some clarity
on uh on this the plan isn't adopted
that has been submitted for examination
carrier and therefore carries weight in
the assessment of this application the
degree of weight to be given to uh to
the neighborhood plan is a matter for
the decision maker so perhaps for myself
and other members of the uh the
committee uh we have just some clarity
there I thought this afforded Norway
because it's not in Conformity with the
mppf so just between 7.7 and 7.1
thank you
yeah I would disagree with the statement
um I think
7.7 to my mind sets out more a general
position on the on the Brampton Parish
neighborhood plan in terms of it the
amount of weight that it would carry in
a decision-making process but I do agree
that it's not set out in policy and not
in conformative with the mppf than the
mppf would take significant priority and
therefore we'd attribute no weight
to the points set out in the plan the
neighborhood plan
Council early
thank you chair as it's uh in my ward
and a couple hundred meters from my
property I think it's only fair that I
should at least ask these questions of
the episodes as well
Adrian I I'm I'm at odds to understand
where you know the the entire country is
actually aiming to go green and and is
trying to help everybody achieve a
better carbon footprint and this is just
one step towards doing that it's hardly
a huge propeller like they've got on the
side of the M18 and and all the wind
farms that are out to sea offshore if
you like
um
and again you know I was going to refer
to probably what some of some of the
speakers referred to it's no higher than
the chimney and the property
it's so in obtrusive that I couldn't
really sit there and on Art and say I'm
against it although I am against
development in the green belt for Green
Bay Bell's sake well this is just a
green initiative it's not a huge
building
and should the applicant wish as he
rightly states he can put this at the
side of his house
with no planning permission required you
can do it under permitted development is
that right Colin
um yeah just to take your first question
thank you in terms of
um obviously there's offices we need to
give substantial weight to the to the
mppf and within that there's footnote 54
which which in this instance
doesn't
really distinct the only reference it
really makes to scale of developments is
to say that wind energy development
involving one or more turbines it does
not make any reference to the scale of
that development so in that in that
regard we have to say that as red and
that very clearly sets out the
circumstances in which wind energy
development is considered not to be
acceptable as is the case here because
it's not identified in the local plan
um in terms of the permitted development
rights you should rightly say there
would be some permitted development
rights afforded for householders but we
can't give significant weight to that if
any because those development rights
don't extend to outside the domestic
coverage of that property therefore we
have to assess it based on the on the
merits of that problem yeah
if you don't mind and I I fully accept
what you're telling me Colin and it does
say that it is in the hands of the
decision maker which is ourselves around
this table
um if somebody can throw a bit of light
to me and explain to me why you know 40
meters is different stood against the
cartilage of the of the chimney should
we say or against a barn where I guess
it's going to house batteries or
whatever it's going to do to put it back
into the grid I don't know because I
don't know anything about nothing
and
and accept that you know if somebody
could tell me about that as well please
I think the fundamental difference is
that that wouldn't fall within the
control of planning offices and we need
to look at it based on the on the policy
context which in this instance that the
overriding factor is the the statement
made in point note 54 paragraph 158
which clearly says that wind energy
development involving one or more
turbines should not be considered
acceptable unless it's in an area
identified suitable for wind energy
development so there are permitted
development rights but in this instance
they wouldn't represent a legitimate
fallback position because the
circumstances are entirely different
based on exciting
thank you Colin chair if you if you may
um yeah absolutely
can you can you tell me if there are any
identified parts of a land within
Northeast Derbyshire District Council
either our own ship or private ownership
where it's possible we could do this as
opposed to this one because I have no
doubt if this came to us and it was
stood against the side of the building
in the cartilage
so is there anywhere designated for it
can you tell me that as I understand it
presently based on on the local plan
there aren't any areas within our
district that are identified as being
acceptable for wind energy developments
yeah the council sits there last week in
states where you know we want to do the
Forefront of of green energy and so on
and so forth and then my new plan like
this is is halted shall we say in its
steps
for 50 meters and the erection of it
against the barn but I accept what
you're telling me so thanks very much
for that I know Adrian's going to tell
me something now I'm just going to in
fact if I could I just re-emphasize what
what Colleen's advised members in the
the position in terms of Our advice to
members is it seems to always to be very
very clear in this instance that there
is no nothing in your own development
plan that would support the application
in terms of how the mppf would be
interpreted and there's nothing actually
in the neighborhood planners coming
forward that identifies an area where
wind power would be appropriate either
but it's just a an objective set out in
the plan and the plan could if it had
wanted
let's address that point should it have
wished so no part of the development
plan shows it in the Brampton Naval plan
has not even achieved examination status
so it doesn't even it hasn't even gone
through the examination where it would
be assessed against in mppf guidance so
from from a point of view of officers
chair I don't think we could be clearer
to members that we don't think there's
any support nationally or locally for
this and we don't actually see that
there's any other mitigating factors
notwithstanding what Professor Ali is
saying in terms about wider objectives
in terms of wind power the position
seems to us to be to be fundamentally
clear and our advice to members is that
it is clear and in our opinion are sent
to be corrected by Lisa if I'm wrong in
this we don't believe in this instance
we have any room for maneuvering
advising you
thanks for explaining that Adrian I
appreciate that
um
yeah we did at least try
uh Council of Fulton
just want to come in with a few points
of clarification just to outline a few
things cancelia is mentioned who
designates the permitted areas for wind
energy who is the authority that can
actually create this various
will be this Council and that process
was gone through when the local plan was
considered an asset did the
administration at the time designate or
attempt a designated no there are no um
on the back of the evidence that was
produced as part of that there's no
attempt to make any areas within the
last four years no the evidence
indicated otherwise so there are none of
those that's the reason why we don't
have that that's right okay
um the next one is um
you mentioned as well Mr Robinson could
put this same structure within a
domestic premises that wouldn't require
any planning is that correct the same
that would be subject to the its
compliance with the relevant permitted
development regulations but as long as
it was within that there is a possible
for him to erect such district there is
scope to um
yeah install wind generated developments
um within a domestic privilege yeah so
the guidelines that we're following the
mppf which is essentially the uh the
guidelines that say State there are no
onshore wind development for onshore
wind when was that updated when was it
released
he's the latest nppf version share was
um published in 2021
so to clarify the mpps and who was that
published by is it government so the
government the current government said
we cannot build wind turbines
except within areas so designated within
a local plan and then with any
um I'll just read footnote 54 if I may
it says that accept for applications for
the repowering of existing wind turbines
a proposed wind energy developed
involving one or more turbines as here
should not be considered acceptable
unless it's in an area identified as
suitable for wind energy developed in
the development plan and following
consultation it can be demonstrated that
planning impacts identified by the
affected local community have been fully
addressed and the proposal has their
backing the second element of that isn't
applicable in this case because there
has been no
um
objections effectively but the first
bullet of that is applicable in this
case and there are no errors then
identified in the council's development
plan is suitable for wind energy
development
so to conclude government has said
no more than what no one or more wind
turbines are not appropriate to be built
that's the guidelines we're getting on
that's the clear policy position
nationally yes that's right we have had
no designated wind areas
uh created
within the previous four years
in your local plan yeah so when that
local plan so the time that that's been
available no designated windows
but in the future
we could design
you could in in any review of your local
plan and or the neighborhood plan could
could do that any neighborhood plans
could do that because that would then
form as if it were made that would form
part of the development plan so as you
can see today the evidence here about
what officers are recommending but I
imagine Mr Robinson may want to to know
how those decisions are you know have
come to those decisions and the
potential for the future essentially but
thank you
[Music]
a big one
going to town
there are sorry
there are wind turbines as members know
around the district but they they were
given permission
before the the moratorium in effect came
into effect
which sorry what moratorium moratorium
referring to Ian and National moratorium
on new onshore wind
proposals which is Manifest in the nppf
right okay and it does predate 2021 but
the latest version of the mppf was
published in 2021 and I think make about
to 2015 2015.
cancel early
thank you Chad yeah I think we can we
can look forward to trying to designate
some some places where we where we can
actually you know permit some
development like we're talking about
flip side to it all is let's not lose
sight then Mr Robinson can put this up
in his cartilage on his farm but not
exactly where he wants it is that right
not necessarily on his farm chair and
not necessarily at 6.5 meters it would
need to conform with the permitted
development allowances within his
domestic cartilage
so that that's his domestic perfect not
his ownership do you know the height of
a major and if uh off the top of your
head if it's let's say bolted to the
premises for one of the better phrase
sadly chair I don't know off the top of
my head but I can advise counselor
Elliott off that chair if he wants to
um thank you Andrew it's set out in the
um the order the relevant order but I'm
afraid I don't know off top of my head I
don't know Lerner's colleagues May yeah
yep I'm getting lots of locations lots
of that chick you know I'll advise
Council to add to the meeting if I'm
Asia when I'm clear about that thank you
Adrian uh councilor voster uh thank you
chair yeah I've listened to a few of the
comments that have been made uh having
been on this like like some of us on
this uh committee a while this is one of
the clearest applications I've seen and
it's very clear the officer's advice
that's been given uh very clear nppf
advice very clear local development of
us couldn't be any clearer and it's it's
in black and white for us to read it and
it's policy we must follow on this we
might like the idea of putting a win
form or considering wind farms and a
take perhaps uh Council Fawcett's Point
yeah it might be a good idea in future
but when you look at developing local
plans they took a lot they take years to
develop with steering groups and lots of
consultations and there's an awful lot
in it what I'm afraid of here is that
you know we might be considering uh
giving permission for something like
this at this community this could set a
very dangerous precedent now I gather
the setting a setting a precedent might
not be a material consideration
absolutely but as soon as any uh any
permission for anything like this is put
forward you will find these go all over
the place once you've given it one the
next agent will come forward and say we
want because they've had one there we've
got to be very very careful at this
first planning committee in this new
Administration so I added some caution
with this one thing we haven't spoke
about that's on the first part
is this
debate or are we because we've not
opened the floor to debate yet I thought
this were questions for officers
with the views we've had they went all
questions to offices and we moved on to
a debate chair I'm happy to carry on at
the bay
is everyone happy to come over the
debate has anybody else got any
questions for officers first
okay I will open the debate thank you
chair uh what we haven't discussed is
that is the latter part and that's uh
the inappropriate development by
definition in the green belt and that's
as clear as clear uh this does have an
impact on the Green Belt it is
inappropriate definition uh
inappropriate development and there's no
very special circumstances throughout
the outweigh the harm cause so when you
look at the recommendations on page
eight to six these was clear as clear
and I think uh Mr kirkham's tried to put
that point forward so
I get the idea that people might want to
support uh wind uh wind development and
understand the new Administration with
green objectives absolutely but
policies very very clear here in its
advice I'm I'm concerned that we might
be setting a precedent if feel people
feel that they might be going against
officers recommendations and if they do
we need very very clear uh motions
putting forward I'm very supportive in
this case the officer's recommendations
thank you chair
foreign
I think we're all very sympathetic I
think to what I'm trying to be achieved
unfortunately as undertight
uh by legal process and and the local
plan so um
I think we'll uh move the debate on and
we'll go and is there any motions
on the floor
you can't cancel around
oh second nature
yes indeed cheers oh just to be clear
that's to move office of recommendations
which is to reject the application
okay chair
counselor Jason
oh
Cooper
counselor Elliot
Council of forces
councilor Foster
that's a hard time or
counselor Lacy for
counselor Leggett for
and councilor Rouse
that's eight four and one against the
motion as pasture
thank you
um
uh thank you um
we want to move on to the next point of
business thanks thanks for your
attendance
and now call on the planning officers to
explain the next report item nine
appeals lodged and determined
we reported all the appeals that have
been received I don't know how long this
goes back but certainly over the last
six weeks manageable note there's been a
number that have been received as always
I'd encourage all members to read and
and take in the comments that are made
on appeal if particularly for new
members you should all be receiving all
appeal decisions electronically and
further to the the election and casually
it's nodding so certainly and that was
happening formally hopefully new members
will be added to that and receive them
going forward it's been some interesting
appeals here that um members may wish to
note and particularly ones within the
green belt that
um Mr Williams at the Fleur De Lis and
Mr leverton at wingworth I've
particularly draw attention to raise
interesting points of clarification so
just um recommend those two to members
share happy as always to take any
comments and just forgot to mention the
the appeals Mr pigott relate to sites
um traveler sites within the green belt
as well which members may find useful in
terms of future considerations
happy to take any questions Jen has
anyone Council Foster thank you Jake I'd
just like to pass my thanks onto
officers great job in uh in sorting
those appeals out so great work thank
you
thank you chair
uh members do we agree to note the
report
yep
I have no urgent business so I now
declare the meeting closed thank you for
your attendance